welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this it's very scary stuff the
deadly coronavirus outbreak that started
in Wuhan China is spreading faster
raising new concerns all around the
globe hospitals in China are packed with
anxious crowds and markets in some areas
we're running out of things to sell 10
Chinese cities with a combined
population of around 33 million people
think about that for a second are now
off-limits an extraordinary scene from
Wuhan at the center of this outbreak a
massive construction effort to build a
new hospital with hopes to have it
finished by Monday the State Department
is warning Americans not to travel to
that part of China amazing pictures
there here in the US ten possible
patients in California one in Texas and
one in Tennessee are in isolation
awaiting CDC test results at least 26
people have died in China and more than
800 are infected in at least eight
countries right now
ramie Inocencio is in beijing for us on
the eve of the Lunar New Year there that
is China's busiest travel season on the
order of 400 million expected to be on
the move ramie good morning what's the
response where you are
good morning that's right Beijing's
motto might as well be keep calm and
carry on but quickly chinese state media
broadcast Chinese President Xi Jinping
enjoying a relaxed and a festive Chinese
New Year banquet but that also is stands
in stark contrast to the jarring
pictures we've been seen coming out of
those lockdown cities not only that
we're getting word now that many major
cultural events to celebrate the holiday
have been canceled not only that next to
me Beijing's Forbidden City famous
around the world stands dark and it is
closed to tourists as of tomorrow this
is how people in Wuhan are responding to
the city's lockdown turmoil at the
supermarkets as shelves go bare and
massive overcrowding and waiting rooms
to get screened at the hospital this
woman cries out for a doctor to save her
life after finding out she has a fever
residents are growing more fearful by
the day of catching the deadly virus
it's quiet
even inside of my apartment it's never
this quiet American scott alice is an
english teacher in Wuhan the government
shut his school down but he says he's
more concerned for people outside Wuhan
including in the US it's walked down but
it's not wide enough that's the part
that I think I'm most concerned with is
that people are still finding ways out
of the city back in the United States
another possible case has popped up in
eastern Texas health officials expect to
find out this weekend if the patient who
had traveled to Wuhan is infected if
there's a confirmed case contact tracing
will begin and all contacts will be
monitored for development of symptoms
but as the number of patients explodes
the World Health Organization has so far
declined to declare the outbreak a
global health emergency
now the race to create a vaccine is on
well the first thing we have to prove is
that we can create a vaccine faster than
certainly we ever have before him at
moderna therapeutics just outside Boston
President Stephen Hogue and his team of
scientists are working with the National
Institutes of Health to research the
corona virus but the distribute of
vaccine globally hoog says they need
federal help there are going to be a
continuing stream of public health
threats viruses that jump into humans
from other species and the longer we
wait to respond the bigger that threat
becomes and that rising threat has even
pushed Shanghai Disneyland to close its
doors not only that as well as 70,000
cinemas across the country that is every
single one Anthony well right now
innocencio for us in Beijing with
everything about that story is alarming